the American lifestyle has gone up and
so our expectations on what is normal is
here and so for families that are living
paycheck to paycheck that are doing this
and sure because you know you have a 600
car loan like there there is still debt
in the picture that is causing less
margin but when something like inflation
hits and eggs and bacon everything goes
up in your grocery bill is like what and
to fill up your car you're looking at
the gas you're like what that stuff in
the moment like that does hurt because
there's not the margin for that extra
hundred extra 200 extra 300 that now is
going out on normal expenses because
what do you normalized where I'm where I
am you know normalized outrageous yes
we've become exp we became uh entitled
to outrageous and so I'm entitled to
this and and so you know inflation then
forced me
to go into that which is absolute
hogwash